devant les fleurs et les bougies une
mère de trois enfants essuie ses larmes
et se questionnent la vis doit être plus
serrée à propos des hommes parce que
c'est pas normal de trouver des enfants
de 15 16 17 ans avoir des armes se
résorbe ça fait quinze ans que judith
paradis a les deux pieds dans saint
michel et la banalisation de la violence
l'inquiète pelli jeunes veulent s'est
fait ajuster s'ils veulent manger leur
leurs frères leurs amis leurs cousins
perdu donc je suis je suis je suis
préoccupé par cette violence là le
problème de fond c'est cesser la
pauvreté le manque de moyens le manque
de perspectives
je pense que les gens ont besoin des
endroits ils ont besoin des lieux où ils
vont sentir accueilli où ils vont sentir
écouté où ils vont s'entre qu'on peut
développer leurs aptitudes à quelques
mètres de l'école sans fenêtre louis
joseph papineau paul evra dirige un de
ces espaces caches tu arrives au centre
lassalien moi j'ai voulu faire une botte
de rêve parce que je me suis dit si
j'arrive dans le nez dans un endroit
comme ici je veux que les jeunes peut se
rêver c'est quoi vos rêves qui la moitié
des rêves que les jeunes me mettais
c'est de manger un repas supplémentaires
à partir de là tu dis que leur société
est une problématique
des jeunes qui étaient sur le point de
déraper il en a rattrapé plusieurs mais
la pandémie a élargi les mailles du
filet pendant 18 mois les jeunes sont
restés isolés à la maison ils n'ont pas
pu et socialiser on n'a pas pu vraiment
travailler avec eux si les répercussions
de ça aussi aujourd'hui conscient que
l'on vit l'absence de modèle de figure
qui tire vers le haut tout le monde nous
en parle dans le quartier des jeunes
qu'ils le montrent par exemple un guide
un grand frère un cousin un ami proche
qui va le donner les bons valeurs
familiales ou les bons valeurs du
civisme pour vivre en société en paix
tous espèrent que la mort de thomas
trudel amènera des changements ici matu
prost radio canada montréal